our columns work pretty well but if we
start putting text in them you can see
that things get pretty cluttered it can
be really difficult to read when the
words are so close to each other in
adjacent columns in design we have a
concept called negative space that is to
say space that doesn't contain anything
on the Udacity website we can see pretty
easy examples of negative space between
this text here in this paragraph and
this icon we have this empty space that
makes it easy for this text to stand out
it makes it much more readable the page
feels less cluttered and our brains
don't have to work as hard to figure out
what this page is trying to tell us to
make this paragraph more legible let's
go into dev tools and add some padding I
will right-click go to inspect element
and we can see that we're selecting this
paragraph this P tag which corresponds
to this text and to make changes just to
this piece of text I'm gonna go to
element style so this is only going to
affect this paragraph I can click in
here and start typing so let's add the
CSS class padding and we'll do 10 pixels
that sounds pretty good and I'll close
this notice that the red box around the
paragraph didn't change but there's some
extra space here already making it much
easier to read padding is a great
strategy to create some negative space
between elements but what if instead of
creating space inside the element we
want to create space outside the element
to do that we'll use margins first off i
refresh the page then I'm going to right
click here and go to inspect element so
once again we're looking at the same
paragraph but things are back to normal
let's make a change now this time we
want to push it away from other elements
so we'll use margin instead margin 10
pixels why not
press ENTER and close dev tools and now
notice how there's a red box around the
paragraph that has some extra space on
the outside between it and the column
for this is called a margin padding was
on the inside
margins are on the outside this is
another great way to create some
negative space between elements if
you're ever confused about what's
creating the space around an element you
can actually look it up in dev tools if
you scroll down to the bottom of this
CSS lists we can see the box model for
the entire page here we've got a margin
of eight pixels which we can see
highlighted then we have a border of 0.8
pixels and then inside the border we
have well no padding because you don't
see any numbers here and then we can see
the size of the screen using the box
model is a great way
figure out how elements are being laid
out on the page if this black box were
an element on the page we've got options
for spacing it out against other
elements margins let us push elements
away from each other while padding's
create space internally in the example
we just looked at we just used the
generic margin and padding to affect all
four sides of the element but we can
also add a side to get a little bit more
specific using either top bottom left or
right